what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and Marvel is going rated R we have a
couple of projects coming to the MCU
that are going to be rated R and are
going to usher in a new side of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe the super
natural side now side note Daredevil
born again could possibly be TV mature
especially since the Punisher is going
to be in that Series so we could have
some kind of rated R like material there
as well now we have Deadpool 3 coming in
that is going to be rated R and then we
have blade this is reportedly according
to Insider Daniel rpk going to be rated
R and that makes sense the old original
blades were rated R And for those of you
who don't know Ryan Reynolds Deadpool
himself was actually in Blade Trinity so
I can definitely see Deadpool doing some
fourth wall breaking talking about that
at some point in time in the MCU when
Deadpool is there and blade is entered
but the darker side of the MCU is coming
and coming very quickly and it seems
very evident from Marvel Studios that
they are going to have specific villains
for specific parts of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe if you've been
following the channel or just following
Marvel news in general you probably know
that Kevin feige has mentioned that the
MCU is kind of going to be divided into
different parts essentially there are
going to be sort of subunits of the MCU
and the subunits are going to have their
own villains their own big bads now Kang
the Conqueror is the overall Multiverse
Saga big bat just like Thanos was the
infinity saga's big bad but throughout
the infinity Saga we had Loki and we had
Ultron now there's a lot more to the MCU
now there are a lot more teams than just
the Avengers or at least there are going
to be Kevin foggy has already mentioned
the street level Avengers team the
cosmic team that is going to take place
at other parts in the Galaxy away from
Earth and then of course we have the
supernatural side coming and it looks
like we know who the big bad for the
Superman natural side is going to be and
that is Mephisto now say all you want
get all the memes out there go ahead
we're all kind of scarred from One
Division and yes it is kind of funny to
talk about Mephisto but more signs point
to the fact that he could be the big bad
of the supernatural side and if we take
a look at all the teams that are coming
this makes sense but we do have some new
information about Mephisto from some
insiders that kind of give us an idea of
how he and possibly she I'll explain in
a bit hold on for a second could pop up
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe so
today we have news about Mephisto news
about blade and news about Agatha coven
of chaos and some small details about
ironheart because Mephisto could show up
in the Iron Heart series and also if
you're ever looking for more information
on any character that we might mention
on the show you can get some help from
my buddies over at comicbookdirect.com
they have created a website and company
that makes comic book shopping the
easiest it can possibly be they deliver
Comics straight to your door you can get
get one-off Comics or you can sign up
for an entire run and get a pretty big
discount if you do so and they'll ship
the latest issue right to your door each
week they have the latest from Marvel if
you're trying to keep up to date with
all the recent projects they have the
latest from DC as well and it's an
all-in-one shop for your Comics
everything that you need in one place
you can sign up for a membership to get
free shipping and a mystery box each
month and the next 100 people to sign up
get 20 off their first order using the
link in the description down below so
like I said we're just going to
specifically talk about the supernatural
side of the MCU and how Mephisto is
looking to be the big bad of this side
and this big bat is going to appear in
several different projects and pop up in
many different ways and the exciting
thing is that ultimately this should
lead to the formation of the midnight
suns in the MCU so a couple of days ago
Insider can we get some toast said this
in response to a tweet that said please
give us something for Agatha in which
The Insider then said here you go my
source from onset has told made the real
villain in Agatha coven of chaos has the
ability to appear in multiple different
forms it is said that they have many
forms and the one that shows up in
Agatha is just one of them now
mephisto's entrance to the MCU was
teased albeit a little bit in one
division but over the past few months
Mephisto has been reported by many
different insiders to be entering the
MCU now there's been a little bit of
confusion because some big trade
companies like deadline have stated that
Sasha Bara Cohen is going to be playing
Mephisto they have said that he is
playing a role in The Iron Heart series
and that role is most likely Mephisto
however on the other hand we have had
some insiders like can we get some toast
and my time to shine hello hint that
Aubry Plaza could be playing Mephisto
and Agatha coven of chaos so we were
confused for a little bit on who exactly
would be playing the demon but the new
report seems to kind of clear that up
Mephisto can apparently take many forms
and that would explain how in one show
he is Aubry Plaza's character a witch
and then another show it's Sasha bear
Cohen it's the same character taking
different forms played by different
actors and honestly if you're the devil
a supernatural super powered being it
does make sense that you would be able
to change forms and it would make sense
to change forms to fit different
situations for example Agatha coven of
chaos obviously it's about Agatha and we
know that Agatha has had the dark hold
before Wanda got it for a very long time
she studied it she knows all about it
but Mephisto would probably also want
the dark hold and Agatha probably caught
mephisto's attention she is a dark witch
using dark magic heck they could be
friends we don't really know but if
Mephisto wanted to sort of get close to
Agatha and sort of infiltrate her coven
what better way than to disguise
yourself as a witch which is the role
Aubry Plaza is apparently going to be
playing that we've been told so far she
is going to be playing a witch in the
coven that Agatha is in let these
insiders have hinted that she could be
Mephisto and it's honestly kind of the
perfect plan disguise yourself as a
witch get into the coven learn
everything you need to learn persuade
people in certain situations to go the
way that you want it's very devilish it
makes sense while on the other hand the
ironheart series we know that the hood
is going to be the villain of the show
and it's been rumored that the hood is
going to get his powers from a certain
demon and then deadline came out and
said Sasha barakowen was playing a role
in the show and is most likely playing
the demon Mephisto so this is just
another situation where Mephisto would
change his form for a certain situation
appearing as Sasha bear Cohen and the
ironheart series has been described as
sort of mechanical Tech like ironheart
is going to use with her Iron Heart
armor versus magic which is the powers
that the hood will have possibly given
to him from Mephisto it's all kind of
lining up now how two different sources
could say Sasha barakone's Mephisto or
Aubry Plaza's Mephisto now it is
important to note that both the Insiders
and deadline have not come out and
stated that these characters are playing
Methodist stuff or sure so it's not
confirmed but it is looking likely
especially if you consider some of the
other teams that are coming to the MCU
and other characters Ghost Rider has
been rumored to be coming for a while
now it's even been rumored that he's
going to get his own special
presentation well if you know anything
about Ghost Rider his powers come from
Mephisto Mephisto is the one who curses
Johnny Blaze and binds him to the demon
zarathos transforming Johnny into the
Blazing spirit of Vengeance Ghost Rider
then there is blade we have recently
heard that Mia goth is going to be
playing the villain Lilith in Blade and
depending on which story of hers you go
by she is actually the daughter of
Mephisto but given that Mephisto is
going to take many forms I'm thinking
that Marvel Studios might actually
change this up a little bit and perhaps
Lilith is going to Simply Be a different
form of Mephisto in the movie It's very
possible or they could stick to the
story and just say that she is the
daughter a Mephisto that still brings
him into the picture so we have several
projects already at Agatha coven of
chaos Iron Heart And Blade that already
seemingly have Mephisto or some sort of
a demon that can take many different
forms appearing in these projects so it
is looking like Mephisto or we'll just
say right now this unnamed demon is
looking to be the big bad of the
supernatural side of the MCU and
hopefully this leads to the formation of
the midnight Suns right now we already
have a lot set for the midnight Suns to
appear and more characters appearing as
the MCU goes on as well right now of
course we have Doctor Strange Moon
Knight Deadpool could be a part of the
team we have Elsa Bloodstone in the MCU
we have blade we also have CLIA coming
in Doctor Strange 3 and Agatha Harkness
as well all characters who have been or
who have at least been associated with
the midnight suns in the comics so just
like the original Avengers built up by
having their solo movies and eventually
going into one big crossover this is
kind of what the sub units are going to
do as well hopefully that way the MCU
really does expand and really does get a
lot bigger then we'll have our big
crossover move movies like Avengers
Secret Wars where all of the different
subunits come together and fight
together or against each other either
way the future of the MCU is looking
very exciting and we're definitely going
to be getting a lot of really
interesting villains coming one of which
is looking to be Mephisto so let us know
your thoughts about all of this in the
comments down below what do you think
about this leave us all of your thoughts
and all of your theories in the comments
section don't forget to like the video
and subscribe and leave a comment so you
can enter our giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel
Legends items and some DC items as well
the winner gets to pick and we pick a
winner at the end of each month and
don't forget to check out our website
that is fully up now and functioning we
post on it every day as always thank you
all so much for watching wolf
baby